when I was dropping out of the
University of Miami and telling
everybody and I'm going to become a
famous stunt man yeah like everybody
legitimately felt sorry for me like it
was just interview like what a tragedy
the great thing about you that I don't
have this you knew from an early age
exactly what you wanted to do and
exactly what you wanted to be you had a
very clearcut vision of what I want
because it's a niche thing to say I want
to be the great stuntman it's like not
many people are you know everybody wants
to be a athlete or an actor but you're
like no no I want specifically that and
you took it to the top Oprah she said
the passion first the money second and
if you follow that rule you'll always be
okay and I was like oh it's true I think
that that really checks out man y